[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Hello, and welcome
to episode 207 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Mark, and I'm here with
my colleague, also mark.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, I'm back
again, for just a little bit.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: For
just a yearly recap,
which is also super
exciting, because it's
a yearly recap of all
the cool things that
have happened in 2019.
MARK MANDEL: I'm basically
doing a John Farnham farewell
tour, which is a joke
only Australians are
going to get because no one
else knows who John Farnham is.
ROBO MANDEL: So true.
So true.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Ha, ha.
I'll pretend to understand that.
[CANNED LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
You can Google it.
It's fine.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I will
Google it after the podcast.
But super excited to be chatting
with Mark for at least one more
reoccurring random
guest appearance--
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
--as we do talk
about all the cool things
that have happened over 2019.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's been a good year.
It's not been terrible.
I can't complain too much.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Minus the
part where you stepped down
as a full-time host,
Mark, which of course is
devastating to all of us.
[AWWS]
MARK MANDEL: But also exciting
because of all the new people
who are on it now and
all the new voices.
And that makes me very happy.
[CHEERS]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
And plus, we always have
Robo Mandel if we need him.
ROBO MANDEL: Glad to
be of service, mate.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
going on with that,
it has been a really cool year.
And I think we'd like
to talk about the top 10
episodes of this year.
But before we dive
into that, I think
we should talk about our
favorite episodes as well.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No, we absolutely should talk
about our favorite episodes.
Why don't you go first?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
So my favorite
episode was definitely
chatting data science
with Chris Albon,
and myself and Michele
hosted that one.
And that's episode 193 if
people are looking for it.
MARK MANDEL: What
was that about?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, so
that episode was super exciting
because we got a chance to
talk with Chris about all
the cool things he's
doing at Devoted Health.
But it was also a lot about
just data science in general.
You know, he was talking
about his machine
learning flashcards,
which I think really
brought a lot of
complex terminology,
a lot of complex different
constructions that
are connected to machine
learning and said,
here's how you can kind
of understand them, access
them, and really get them
in a way that really lowered
the barrier to entry.
And I think he was talking a
lot about the human side of data
science and where the
actual application
was far more
important than running
all these large studies.
Machine learning and
data science in general
are all becoming a
little bit easier to do.
So he was much more
interested in, well,
what are you doing with them?
Where is the impact of those?
And so that
conversation with Chris
was really fascinating
because he drove
into why that's so important.
And that's why Devoted Health.
But really all the
things that Chris
talks about really drive more
into impact than anything else.
MARK MANDEL: Very, very cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: What
about your favorite episode?
MARK MANDEL: So I've got
a couple of favorites.
It's actually interesting noting
that neither of our episodes
are in the top 10 downloads.
But that's kind of because
we have diverse backgrounds
of interests.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: I particularly
liked doing blockchain
with Allen Day.
And I want to say
that non-ironically.
I think in the tech
industry, we maybe
make fun of this maybe a
little bit more than we should.
I don't know.
It definitely comes up a lot
in random jokes and whatnot.
But it was awesome.
I don't know really anything
about blockchain or bitcoin
mining or anything along
those kind of lines.
So to sit down with
Allen and be like, OK,
what does this thing do?
What is it actually useful for?
What can you do in GCP with it?
It was really good from a
very practical point of view
and just kind of be like,
OK, let's kind of go
through the hype,
get through that,
and then be like, OK,
what's the reality here?
What is that
actually useful for?
And that was super interesting.
And some of the stuff
we have going on
with BigQuery and some
cryptocurrency type stuff
was super interesting too.
And it was also really
good fun because it
was the first time I got to
be on the podcast with Carter
Morgan.
And I really like Carter,
so that made me very happy.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
it was an awesome episode.
And honestly,
anything that brings
a little bit more
realistic understanding
of what blockchain is--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: --I think
we just need more of that.
So introducing the
Google Cloud Blockchain
podcast, where everything
is blockchain every episode.
ROBO MANDEL: Awesome.
I'll call Rebel Wilson, and
maybe we can host it together.
MARK MANDEL: Let's
not go that far.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: OK, no
blockchain podcast yet.
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
Do you have any other
favorite episodes?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: The
Chris Albon episode
was a really great
one for data science.
We actually got to talk
to another fella, John,
from Primer AI.
You know, again, this was
a host that Michelle had
worked very hard to bring in.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And we got
to hear some really interesting
stories.
I think John shared
just a fascinating life
story of how he got to data
science and where he is
and all the cool things
that he does now.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, very cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I thought
that was a really good listen.
But it was really just
fascinating to hear
about the 18 different
paths he took.
And that story mentioned
a lot about working
with the government, and working
with some very interesting
companies in China, and
testing fish for pregnancy.
I mean, it went
all over the place.
MARK MANDEL: It's always
super interesting, I
find, listening to some
stories that people take,
especially people with
nontraditional backgrounds,
about how they get into tech
and the career development
they've had, how they ended
up where they ended up.
Because I feel like with tech,
there's no one true path.
And it's always very
interesting to see
how people ended up here.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Like you said, there's
such a diverse background.
And most of the times, these
people aren't starting in tech.
They're starting with
much more focused areas
of what they wanted to go into
and then just ended up in tech
because they have that
background expertise.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, absolutely.
So one of my other favorite
ones that I want to bring up,
which is episode 196, which is
the episode with Phoenix Labs,
if anyone played "Dauntless."
I have to mention
something to do with games.
I think it's just a given.
I really liked this
episode, not only
because cool game and stuff,
and [INAUDIBLE] Kubernetes,
et cetera, et cetera.
The thing I like
about this is it's--
we've definitely done stories
talking about the PSO team
and some of the sales
support teams and how
we do things from the Google
side to support customers.
But it was really great to
hear from the customer side of,
what was it like
as an experience
to launch a
large-scale game that
was through the roof in terms of
beyond the expectations of what
they were going to get
traffic wise and player wise,
and then see what their
perspective was on the support
they were getting from
the Google Cloud team
and how they were
supported at launch.
Unsurprisingly, given
it's the podcast,
it was relatively positive.
[LAUGHTER]
But it was really interesting
just to see their perspective
and sort of give some
ideas for other people
who are looking to maybe launch
some large-scale things how
Google Cloud can help them.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, I thought
we got a good perspective of
that on the Supersolid episode
as well--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice, yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
--where they talked a lot
about using Agones, of course,
and kind of their process
there before it was
1.0 and the experience
they had working with Google.
And obviously, they also had
a great experience with it.
But it was very cool for them to
talk about these two engineers
who didn't have any
Kubernetes experience going
into launching full-scale
back end for gaming
and how they did that.
That was super, super cool.
So definitely another
episode worth checking out.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So the reality is,
is every episode
is our favorite,
I think, is what
this comes down to.
MARK MANDEL: Well, the episodes
that aren't our favorites,
we're not going to mention.
I don't want to
make anyone upset.
No, I'm kidding.
They're all fantastic.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: They're
all fantastic episodes.
But it would be worth
to mention that we
do have the top 10 episodes as
rated by the viewer, I guess,
by the episode views.
So we'll call that
rated by the viewers.
MARK MANDEL: That works.
So I'm in a lot of them.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: There's a lot.
Well, you know what that means.
People really like
hearing you talk.
MARK MANDEL: Though
you're in the top one.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I am
in the top one, which
makes me feel so good inside.
But I know it wasn't
because of me.
It was because-- well,
we'll come back to that.
MARK MANDEL: I was
because of Gabi, really.
It was because of Gabi.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It was
because of Gabi, 100%.
We'll talk about that
when we go there.
But shall we start from
the bottom up, then?
MARK MANDEL: OK, let's do that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: All right,
well then let's start with--
I guess a drum roll would
be appropriate here.
[DRUM ROLL]
Episode number 10, which
we have as Cloud SQL.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: This one
was Mark and Gabi as well.
Gabi talks a lot about Cloud
SQL and other database solution
offerings as well.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But
what were your takeaways
from that episode?
MARK MANDEL: I actually
really liked this episode.
It actually hearkens me
back to a number of years
ago where we did an episode on
just straight GC EVMs, which
was also hugely popular.
Cloud SQL.
It's just a staple of
things that people need.
We work in DevRel,
and sometimes it's
very nice to show up and
do all the shiny stuff
and just be like,
oh my god, look
at this cool new thing
that shows up and does
this amazing stuff.
Sometimes you just need to
stick stuff in a database.
So it's always
great to just have
this sort of workhorse type
technology to talk about it
and just get it done.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, I know
MySQL Postgres aren't going
anywhere anytime soon,
and it's definitely
a need for a lot of people.
So it sounds like that
would be a cool episode
to check out if you want a
refresher on maybe what's
new with Cloud SQL.
And I'm sure there's
plenty more coming up.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
So coming in at number 9--
[DING]
--episode 168 with
myself and Jon Foust.
Jon meeting with
Ian and Kari talking
about NVIDIA and their T4 chip.
This was lots of fun as well.
We got to actually go down to
the NVIDIA headquarters, which
honestly, if you haven't
seen photos of the NVIDIA
headquarters, is the most
on-brand campus I've ever
seen in my life.
All their NVIDIA branding
looks like their building.
It's all black triangles.
It's gorgeous.
It's also a lovely building.
But, yeah, we got to have
a really great conversation
about accelerated computing,
and machine learning, and all
the stuff that the new T4
chip allows them to do.
Lots and lots of good,
fun stuff around that.
And of course you can
get the T4 chip now
in GCP, which was
the whole point.
And you can do neat stuff.
Most of it was
just above my head.
[LAUGHTER]
But it all sounded fantastic.
I'm like, yes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, I
think everyone definitely
wants more GPUs for
whatever process
or whatever workloads
they're using
that are more GPU-focused.
But I'm kind of jealous of
actually going to the campus
and seeing what that looks like.
MARK MANDEL: And
Jon was super happy
because the RTX series had just
come out for the NVIDIA chip.
So he was like, oh my
god, I'm at NVIDIA.
And so it was awesome.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Sounds
like a lot of fun.
Well, on episode number 8--
[DING]
--WE have human-centered
AI with Di Dang.
So Di is a Google
Developer advocate as well,
but focusing more
on the AI side.
[BUZZER]
Actually, I think she's
a design advocate.
[PLUNK]
Yes, design advocate at Google.
That was you and I, Mark.
And we got to sit down with Di--
she's a design advocate here
at Google--
and talk about the
human-centered AI
guidebook that
they were creating,
which is really a
set of best practices
and things to think about
when creating an AI system,
especially a dialog
system, to talk with people
and what kind of
best practices you
should keep in mind for that.
I thought it was really
interesting to hear
about the kind of things.
One that really
stuck with me was
this idea of personification
and turning non-people type
objects into people and how
that really impacts especially
younger minds when they're
interacting with AI.
I thought there were some really
fascinating tips in there.
And AI is not nearly
my area of expertise,
but it was really cool to kind
of see someone taking a stance
and saying, here's some research
that backs up these best
practices, and here's
what we recommend you do.
As opposed to what
is happening now,
is just explosion of all these
different AI systems being
built, possibly
without guidelines,
so they could be
all over the place.
MARK MANDEL: A super
interesting episode as well.
They released
something, didn't they?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, they
had the actual guidebook
was released shortly
after that episode.
So definitely recommend
people check that out.
It's in the show
notes down there.
But it was kind of
fascinating to see
what that actually
looked like and what they
were recommending people do.
MARK MANDEL: OK, number seven.
[DING]
174, is professional
services, which
I got to do with Aja
Hammerly which it's awesome.
This is just basically a
list of my favorite people.
So we got to meet with
Anne Wallace and Michael
Wallman talking about
Professional Services
Organization, or PSO.
Basically they're the
post-sales department.
This was just really cool to
see how the PSO team works
with customers to help them
build some of the things
that they need to
get built, basically.
So they go through
some customer examples,
and they went through some
things that they have worked on
and how they'd helped
certain people.
And we touched on a whole
bunch of stuff, from SRE, CRE,
to consulting services, to
all the products, basically.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Which
is very reflective of how
the PSO org works for Google.
When they're working
with customers,
it'll be anything
from implementation
to support or training and
then across the entire breadth
of Google Cloud products.
So it makes sense
that there would be
a wide variety covered there.
Sixth on the list--
[DING]
--we have episode 164, which
was Node.js with Myles.
Mark, that was you and
Jon talking about it,
but I know from
talking with Myles,
he is always excited to lay
down some serious knowledge
on Node.js.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Did I mention this is
basically just a list
of my favorite people?
Again, Myles.
Yeah, it's all the
Node.js things.
What was cool, I actually
liked about this as well, is we
kind of just went through
all the different ways
Node.js touches Google Cloud.
And it's a long list.
I mean, we covered
also the stuff
that was kind of internal,
so how Node.js works,
and some of the fun things
about the governance,
and all that kind of stuff.
But it was actually just really
cool to be like, OK, where
are all the things that Node.js
goes through from App Engine,
to Apps Script, to BigQuery,
to all this kind of stuff.
So if you're a
Node.js developer,
check out this episode.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, and definitely
if you're interested
in Node, follow Myles.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
Myles is great.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: He
talks a lot about Node,
and he's a really great guy.
So definitely recommend
checking him out.
MARK MANDEL: So number five--
[DING]
--halfway there.
Oh, look, it's you and me
again, meeting with Jen Person--
again, favorite persons.
So Jen's great.
Jen gave us a update on what's
been happening with Firebase.
Cloud Firestore had just
come out of beta at the time,
and Cloud Functions for Firebase
was also out at that point.
And so Jen gave us
a whole walkthrough
of all kinds of cool stuff
that's going on with Firebase.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: All kinds
of cool information there.
MARK MANDEL: Just all
the cool stuff, yeah.
Jen's fantastic.
You should follow Jen.
Jen's now working, I
believe, on Google Cloud.
So you can follow her
for Google Cloud stuff.
But, yeah, Jen's fantastic.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Definitely excited
to see all of the new
stuff Jen's working on.
But, yeah, she was also very
heavily ingrained with Firebase
for the past two years or so.
So this conversation earlier
this year, just everything
Firebase.
So definitely recommend checking
it out if you all are big
Firebase fans.
Next up, number four--
[DING]
--getting close.
We've got Knative,
Mark, that was you
and Gabi talking to some great
people about what Knative is.
And of course the first
question that comes out of this
is, what is Knative?
MARK MANDEL: What is Knative?
ROBO MANDEL: It's probably a
delicious low-fat breakfast
cereal.
[BUZZER]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It is a--
I'd like to call it an open
source platform as a service.
So it's an opinionated tool
chain for building applications
on top of Kubernetes and
deploying and audio scaling
and all that kind of fun stuff.
But, yeah, it was interesting.
Around that time, Knative
had really sort of
hit the scene, so to speak.
Everyone was pretty
excited about it.
So we got a really
good opportunity
to go through what
Knative is, what it does,
how it works, how you
can get started with it,
listen in on some of the
history behind it as well.
So, yeah, it's one of the
hot things going on, Knative.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And as a spoiler,
it's not the last time
we'll hear about Serverless
on Kubernetes in this list.
MARK MANDEL: Probably not.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But
before we talk about that,
we'll go to episode three-
[DING]
--which was episode 175,
talking about Mongo Database.
That was you and Jon
talking about all the things
that were Mongo.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
this is great.
We had a great chat
with Andrew Davidson
from MongoDB talking about,
first of all, what is MongoDB?
NoSQL databases as a
whole and how they work.
And it was also really
interesting to hear
about their commercial product,
MongoDB Atlas, which you
can run on top of Google Cloud.
So if you're looking for a
managed platform from MongoDB,
that can be a great
opportunity for you as well.
So coming in at number two--
[DING]
--we have Python
with Dustin Ingram.
Speaking of favorite people,
also joined by Brian Dorsey.
Brian and Dustin fantastic.
Just doing a recap of
what's going on with Python
on Google Cloud, very
much like when we talked
with Myles about Node,
talking about all the really
interesting, cool stuff
that's going on with Python
and all the places it can
touch in Google Cloud,
including things
like Cloud Functions
and how we support things like
Flask, one of their frameworks,
and all kinds of
other fun things--
App Engine, yadda, yadda,
yadda, all the cool things.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
I talked to Dustin
after this episode
came out, and he
was really surprised
with just how
many people are interested
in hearing more about Python.
First of all, of course.
MARK MANDEL: There's a
couple of Python developers
out there, just a few, just
a couple here or there.
Yeah, right?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I hear it's
an up-and-coming language.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I heard that he
was really excited to see
what the response was.
And obviously Dustin
works a lot on Python.
But the reality is, very similar
to some of the other episodes
we've been seeing here,
it's really about how
these things work across
the entire cloud ecosystem
and what you can do with them.
If you know Python, great.
Bring that to cloud.
You don't really need
to learn a new language
or do anything like that.
Much easier.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
All right, last one.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That leaves us
with the first and top episode
of this year.
[DING]
We're not editing
a drum roll here.
We're going to put the
episode on pause until Mark
does a actual drum roll.
[DRUMMING ON TABLE]
There it is.
And our number one
episode was Cloud Run.
[FIREWORKS]
Hinting at it a few
times throughout here.
But it was actually an episode
that we recorded at Next.
And those episodes were
fantastic, although admittedly
just a caffeine-fueled
couple of days
where we tried to stay awake for
all the events and activities.
But we also got a great
chance to sit down
with a huge number of people as
they came by the Google Cloud
podcast booth and talked about
a wide variety of things.
Well, in this episode, I
think the real key cornerstone
of this was us talking to
Steren and Ryan about Cloud Run.
So they're both product
managers here at Google.
And they were kind
of announcing,
because this had also
come out at Cloud Next,
was the beta for Cloud Run,
and basically this idea
of being able to serverlessly
serve a container,
and it's backed by Kubernetes
and really Knative.
It's this managed
container serving offering.
And everyone was super
excited about it.
And I think that was
kind of just the greatest
kind of conversation to
understand, what is this?
And we haven't seen this before.
We've seen some similar things.
Why is it exciting?
And it sounds like people really
were interested in hearing more
about it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It sounds like this is
was a really cool thing.
Not entirely shocked that
this is number one, at all.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: No.
It's such a huge
conversation topic
right now, and especially
as more and more
people get used to
the ecosystem and what
that looks like, I think we'll
be hearing a lot more cool use
cases and seeing,
oh, look at this kind
of possible architecture that
was just not doable until Cloud
Run came around.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Cloud Run is pretty neat.
I should sit down
and play with it.
It seems like
something I should do.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
It's super fun.
Definitely highly recommended.
And actually, it turns
out, it's super easy.
In fact, I know a podcast
episode you should probably
listen to about it.
MARK MANDEL: I listen to
all the episodes, mostly,
some of the time.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, this one was--
because it was a
Next episode, we
did get a lot of
different people in there.
And it was great to
definitely talk about that.
And I highly recommend
checking that out, as well
as the other 10 episodes
we mentioned, but also
the 200 before those,
just because it turns out
we talk about a lot
of great things.
[DING]
MARK MANDEL: Before we
finish up for the year, Mark,
what's been your favorite
things this year?
What stuff have you been
particularly excited
about announcement wise?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, like I said,
we've talked about so
many different things.
I think Cloud Run is
probably the coolest thing
that we've talked
about because it's just
such an effortless and cool way
to look at hosting containers.
I know you're a
huge Kubernetes fan.
MARK MANDEL: Little bit.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And maybe you
bring it up every once or twice
an episode.
But sometimes you just want
to host your container,
and you don't want to
deal with the rest.
MARK MANDEL: 100%.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And that's where
Cloud Run, when I heard about
it, I was super excited.
I've had a chance to play
around with it a bit.
And I'm really looking
forward to just doing
everything that way now
because I don't want to YAML.
I just want to--
MARK MANDEL: Just make it work.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Just do it, right?
MARK MANDEL: Just do it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So that
has, by far this year,
been the coolest thing I've had
a chance to see and talk about.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
We haven't mentioned this
on the podcast, actually,
but I just want to
say, as a Google
thing that has just
got me very excited,
the Stadia launch, games.
I mean, Stadia is magic, man.
Ah, it's so good.
Because of this, I can't
put down "Samurai Showdown."
It's one of the free pro
games because I signed up.
And I keep playing it,
and it's wonderful.
First of all, I just
think it's super cool.
Second of all, just massive
congratulations to that team
for just pulling off something
that is just technologically
genre breaking, and as far
as I'm concerned, pure magic.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
You want to talk about
things that may not
have been possible before
this kind of introduction,
this ability to
stream all the cloud
resources to your computer.
I know that I didn't
need yet another surface
to play "Destiny" on,
and yet here I am.
MARK MANDEL: Here you are, yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
Now I just need to be
able to play "Destiny"
on three surfaces at once.
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
There you go.
So it's fine.
If you can play on your Switch.
Can you play Switch?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: No, but
I really wish I could.
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
If you could play Switch, plus
your console, plus your PC,
plus Stadia.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Just drain
all the internet from my house
and all the life
from my activities.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You don't need to go outside.
But yeah, so Stadia is one of
my favorite things of the year.
I just also want to say another
favorite thing of the year,
it's really delightful to
hear all the new voices
on the podcast as well
and hear all the new hosts
and what a great job
you're all doing.
It was bittersweet
to step down, but I'm
super happy to hear
everything that's
going on with the podcast
with all of you all.
So, yeah, nice job, everyone.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, I
can definitely say thank you
because I'm right here.
And I'm sure many
of our other hosts
share the sentiment,
because it's just
been so exciting to get this
broad range of people talking
about all these
different things.
It's just super cool, and it
adds a lot of cool perspectives
to all the
conversations we have.
So hopefully all the listeners
are also enjoying the mix up
of different topics
and different hosts.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Cool.
All right, so
where are you going
to be before you
finish up for the year?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, we are coming
to the end of the
year, which means
it's a little bit of the holiday
season if you're into holidays.
If not, then it's just kind
of December and January.
Either way, I'm going to sleep.
I'm going to take a
nice bear hibernation.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Maybe stay in
my room for about three months
probably, playing Stadia.
How about yourself?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I would
like to take a break.
Unfortunately,
everything is already
ramped up for next year, so--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh no.
MARK MANDEL: All the planning
for Game Developers Conference,
all the planning for
Google Cloud Next,
all the planning for IO.
That's just kicking
on, kicking on.
So I'll be doing that because
this train never stops.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Just finding a way
to make it to the next stop.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, but probably
doing a lot of lying down
in bed with my dog.
It'll be fine.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That's
the exciting part.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
it's been a fantastic year,
and always super excited
to chat with Mark.
I'm sure you'll probably
see him in one or two
other future episodes
as cool things come up
or we get more Agonus
related content.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe.
We'll see.
No promises.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We'll see.
We'll see.
Well, to all the
listeners/viewers--
it doesn't matter how
you're listening to this--
very, very excited to have you
all with us through this year.
And hopefully we will see
you early next year as well.
ROBO MANDEL: Hang
on a second, fellas.
Gabi and Jon have
recorded a special bonus
segment for the holidays.
So without further
delay, here we go.
GABI FERRARA: I am Gabi, and
I'm here with my colleague, Jon.
Hello, Jon.
How are you?
JON FOUST: I'm
doing pretty well.
Had a lot of fun at
the holiday party.
[LAUGHS]
GABI FERRARA: That was fun.
Everybody was so fancy.
JON FOUST: Yeah it was.
You looked really
nice yesterday.
GABI FERRARA: Yay.
I was like, I'm going
to dress up, just
for one occasion of the year.
So, Jon, today is the last
episode of the year, right?
[DING]
JON FOUST: Yep,
IT definitely is.
And it's been a very,
very interesting year
full of very, very
interesting guests
and really new and
interesting product updates.
So it was definitely
a lot of fun
getting to talk about all
those things on the podcast.
GABI FERRARA: Oh yeah,
definitely a lot of new hosts--
JON FOUST: Yes.
GABI FERRARA: --too.
I don't remember
everybody's name
right now because there's people
that I didn't have the pleasure
to record with yet.
JON FOUST: Right.
GABI FERRARA: But I'm happy
that we have all these people
collaborating with us.
So, Jon, let's talk
about favorite episodes.
JON FOUST: One of my
favorite episodes we did
together was the data
visualization with Manuel Lima.
And that was really
fun because we
got to talk to pretty much the
creator of a brand-new team,
built specifically in seeing
metrics around products
internally and
making things work.
And it was just awesome because
he was just full of energy.
You weren't in
the room with him,
but he was just
glowing with excitement
from just talking about
data visualization.
It was just amazing.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
That's one of my
favorites for the reason
that it's an inter-department
effort that he does,
not just his own department,
but a lot of products
he helps with, like
visualization for BigQuery,
and also he works together
with team of material design.
So I learned a lot with him.
We wanted to do another
episode with him.
JON FOUST: Yeah, we did.
GABI FERRARA: I'll tell you
what my second favorite one,
was I recorded with Mark
Mandel and was the pi world
record with Emma.
JON FOUST: Ah,
yeah, that's right.
GABI FERRARA: Emma Haruka, Iwao.
Yeah, it was really fun.
She was very excited
about all the work,
and she explained
how she figured out
machine configurations to
make it work for calculating
that amount of digits of pi.
JON FOUST: When I
talked to Emma about how
she went about creating
it, she told me
that she had already been
running it for several days.
And that was months,
actually, right?
I think she ran it for
a couple of months.
When I heard that, I
was like, our GCP bill
is going to be really expensive.
[LAUGHTER]
Emma really put her heart
and soul into that project.
And I'm glad that she not only
won a Guinness World Record.
But it was just amazing
to know that we actually
know the person on a team that
really put forth this effort
and really accomplished
something really amazing.
GABI FERRARA: And
she's very accessible.
She has her feet on the ground.
She's one of my
favorite persons.
And she likes my coffee, too.
JON FOUST: Well, I don't
know about feet on the ground
because she's always traveling.
So if you ever happen to bump
into Emma in any country,
just know that she
pretty much just loves
being everywhere else.
So another one of
my favorite episodes
is the Phoenix Labs episode
that we did with Jessie Houston.
Mark and I sat down,
and we got to talk
to the CEO of Phoenix Labs.
And it was amazing
because we got
to talk to them about the
process, working with Google
and getting ready for
launch of "Dauntless."
And if you haven't played
"Dauntless," it's really fun.
I played it several
times before our podcast,
and I played it for I think
a month or two after before
other new games came out
and I just started adding
more games to my backlog.
So it was really
interesting to hear
how they had engineers come
into their war room right
before launch,
and they were just
crunching through everything
and debugging and pretty much
just going over metrics
and quotas and making sure
that everything was
perfect for launch.
And it was just really
interesting to see
that full cycle of working
with our internal teams
to make sure that their
launch was successful.
GABI FERRARA: The
concept of working
that much together to
launch something cool,
it's priceless because
you learn new things.
And also there's
the adrenaline jump.
Like, oh my god,
I need to do this.
And then when you launch,
you're so apprehensive.
Is this going to fail?
Is this going to work?
So my other favorite
episode that's
one that we did together, Jon.
It's with Zack Akil,
where he talks about ML
things and his awesome demos.
JON FOUST: I'm a big fan of
Zack and him being a maker
and just taking all of
his personal interests.
And you can see it reflects
on the demos that he does,
but they're so informative.
And they're really
complex projects that
span several products of GCP.
So it's really cool to see him
really taking his interests
and running with it and
building really cool things.
GABI FERRARA: It's one of
your favorites too, right?
JON FOUST: Yeah, for sure.
And Zack is probably one
of my favorite people
as well, solely because he
and I share not only a lot
of these same interests, but
we are both makers as well,
and we both try to incorporate
our personal interests
in all of our projects.
So I can see Zack and I
being really good friends
for a really long time.
[LAUGHS]
GABI FERRARA: That's cool.
Definitely having nice people in
your life makes things better.
Zack, he was a bit
shy in the beginning,
but he came through in the
end, really nice personality.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
GABI FERRARA: My
other favorite episode
is with SeMI Technologies
with Laura ham.
JON FOUST: Oh, yeah,
I remember that one.
We did it together too, right?
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
She talked about
knowledge graph, which
I did even know much about it.
I can't explain it.
Go to episode 198 if you
want to listen to it.
And she has the same profession
as us, developer relations.
So she talks a bit
about how she does
use her work for the
company and Weaviate, which
is their open source too
for the knowledge graph
that they work on.
And it was nice
seeing someone also
passionate about what they do
and helping build a product
that they are talking about.
JON FOUST: I really
enjoyed that episode
because I got to talk
about the meaning of things
as it pertains to
knowledge graphs,
and how the meaning of one
word can mean something
in one universe versus
another universe.
And if you listen
to that episode,
you get to listen
to me really rant
and go on and on
and on about this.
Because I compare how
medicine may be one way in,
like Harry Potter's universe,
versus our universe.
So definitely a lot of fun, and
Laura was just really great.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah,
she was awesome.
JON FOUST: And my
final favorite episode
was with FACEIT
with Maria Scuri.
That episode was really fun
because it's not every day
that I get to talk to
women who work in gaming.
And it was really
interesting to know
that someone is taking the
time to really make gaming
a friendly place where they're
trying to fight toxicity
within games.
So I got to sit down
with Brian, and we
got to really pick
her brain about what
makes things very
toxic in games,
what is the common trends that
you see in toxicity in games.
And we got to see the technology
that FACEIT has built running
on GCP to actually fight this.
So it's something that I openly
admitted that I participated in
on the podcast.
It's just great to know that
there's a platform to actually
make gaming a better place.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah, definitely.
We need more of that.
We see things that happen.
And having someone that
worries about that,
it's definitely important.
JON FOUST: And it's
actually kind of funny
because I have friends who
tell me that they would never
play online competitive
multiplayer games strictly
because of how toxic it is.
So hopefully we can
change their minds.
GABI FERRARA: There is
also places on the internet
that I don't go because
of that same reason.
I just don't go there.
So that's up for our
favorite episodes.
What did you do this
year that you liked?
JON FOUST: One of
my favorite things
was when I first
joined Google, I
got to see Mark and
Melanie doing the podcast
in the middle of Next in 2018.
And this year, I got
to be a part of that.
So we were smack dab
in the middle of Next,
and we got to do
the podcast, and we
had a whole bunch of people come
through and do small episodes.
Some of them didn't
make the cut,
but it was just really great
to talk to all these people,
see the interesting things
they were building up.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah,
that was a lot of fun.
I remember that day.
Unfortunately not all
episodes, because we
recorded the whole day of
stuff, and so many things didn't
make it.
But it definitely gave us
ideas to bring more people in.
JON FOUST: We actually
brought some of those guests
back as full episodes as well.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah, Cloud
Run I think was one of them.
JON FOUST: Another cool
thing was for an episode,
I got to go to NVIDIA's office,
and that was extremely fun.
Mark and I went together.
And he always says NVIDIA has
one of the best branded offices
as far as color schemes,
because everything
is black glass and green
highlights everywhere.
And their office
is extremely nice.
And I won't say
whose food is better,
but I will say that they
had a very good selection.
GABI FERRARA: It depends on
the office you go at Google.
It depends a lot.
And then you get--
[LAUGHTER]
--amazing food and good food.
JON FOUST: And
another thing was I
got to talk to a
lot of guests that
are in the gaming
industry, mostly
women, which is really great.
And I got to hear
how passionate they
are and see about the cool
things they're building on GCP.
And just hearing all of
these experts in this field
really inspires me to
continue to do lot of the work
I try to do.
It's really
interesting, and that's
one of my favorite things
from the podcast as well.
GABI FERRARA: Favorite
thing, where it all started,
which is joining the podcast.
And that has been on adventure.
Getting to research and learn
because we want to make right
by our audience, and there
is stuff that sometimes we're
not experts.
We can't be experts
and know everything.
But it makes for good episodes
because we ask questions
that we want to learn from those
people that we're interviewing.
There has been a cool thing
to be doing in this year.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
I will say that I
learned quite a bit.
It was just amazing
knowing that I
got to learn a lot
from our guests,
and I got to learn a
lot from the hosts that
came before me, like Mark, who
taught me a bunch of things.
The audience doesn't know,
but one of the funniest things
that I think for us, with the
podcast, when we first joined
was you and I did not
have the right equipment.
So in our first
episodes, I don't
think our audio was that great.
GABI FERRARA: Or
it was standing in.
Yeah, like when it
got like, oh my god,
how much I put the
[INAUDIBLE] on the microphone.
The editors do magic.
JON FOUST: Yeah, yeah,
thanks to our editors.
So, Gabi, what about your
favorite things of the year?
GABI FERRARA: So beyond
joining the podcast,
I got to visit at
a lot of offices.
We do have an internal
competition on that,
but nothing like the people
that has been there for awhile.
But definitely I got to
see London and in Portugal.
Because I was on vacation.
I was like, I'm going
to go to the office
just to see how it
is and eat the food.
[LAUGHTER]
Because that's what you do.
JON FOUST: Not only do we
badge into every office,
but tasting the food
and comparing it
because everyone says, this
office has the best food.
This office has the best food.
And being able to go to that,
that is definitely pretty fun.
Although I'm not big on
trying everything at cafes.
I like to stick to what I'm
used to so I can actually
make very informed decisions
about which food is better.
GABI FERRARA: Oh, that's
a good idea, yeah.
I like the noodles in
that office in New York.
It's really good.
JON FOUST: Oh, yeah.
[LAUGHS]
GABI FERRARA: So
another one that I
like-- people may find it weird,
but I did a talk on Cloud Next,
and my demo failed.
But what I liked
about it, it's like I
was able to recover from
it and deliver the talk.
Because one of the
points I was making,
Jon, is like how
unreliable it is to do
local development sometimes.
And it actually failed locally.
But it worked on the cloud.
So in the end, it
was a good thing.
JON FOUST: That's really cool.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah, it was
like, it works on the cloud.
That's what I wanted to show.
JON FOUST: You
know what's funny?
I find that our audience
is-- during our talks,
because I've also had
a demo fail this year--
they learn quite a bit
from seeing our demos fail,
see that they're real things,
and then being able to recover
and still pass along
that information.
And even have some success
coming out of the failed demos
is really good
for our audiences.
So I can definitely
relate to you on that one.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
It's funny because
I don't panic.
In high-stress situations,
actually my mind
enters in gears.
And I'm able to do stuff
that I wouldn't be doing
if it was a normal situation.
And that was nice because, pro
tip, do not debug your demo.
If nobody failed, just
don't go deep there
because it's a rabbit hole.
And I'm glad that
I didn't do that.
That was a good decision.
And while I was doing that,
one of my favorite things
was also spreading
the love on databases.
I know a lot of people
think databases are boring.
But I find it awesome.
I find it awesome being able to
put things on their own place.
And database normalization,
how you organize your data,
and learning different types.
Because it's not a competition.
There's things-- like if
you use Redis for gaming
because you need fast caching,
you need session saving,
putting that on the relational
database, for instance,
it's not ideal.
That is what I like
bringing to the people,
the awareness of all the
options that you have there.
But not for you to
replace it, but for you
to have an informed decision
of what you put on your stack.
So that's one of the
things I like doing.
JON FOUST: You're just as
passionate about database
as I am with gaming.
GABI FERRARA: [LAUGHS] Which
makes us good in our jobs.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
GABI FERRARA: Definitely.
Not perfect, but good.
JON FOUST: Another
favorite thing of the year,
just really small, would
probably be on the podcast,
it would probably be the
numerous amount of outtakes
that we do.
And they're hilarious.
I wish we could just do an
episode just of outtakes.
I love how the humming became
a thing on one of the episodes.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
JON FOUST: When I passed
that along to my friends
and everybody was
listening, they
were like, OK, that's
something you would totally do.
GABI FERRARA: [LAUGHS] So
where are you going to be?
JON FOUST: Well, it's
the end of the year,
so I'm going to be home,
hopefully playing some games,
but mostly planning gaming
content for next year
and just wrapping up this
year with a lot of deep dive
into multiplayer games,
how they're built,
and a lot of
trade-offs and trying
to optimize and really make
the gaming products that we
are trying to build out
very good for our developer
communities.
Depending on how deep my dive
into the multiplayer game
stuff, I may actually push
out some content right
before the end of the year.
If you're following,
look out for it.
How about you, Gabi?
GABI FERRARA: So
winter is coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And I can't stand
winter much, so I'm also
having vacation, where I'll be
running away to warm weather.
So no winter for me.
I mean, not much.
I'm still going to be
here in January, February.
But on the end of
the year, I just
want to be on the
beach, which is nice.
JON FOUST: Another favorite
thing on the podcast,
I love how Gabi just sets
up all of our sound clips.
I think she
purposely puts winter
is coming for a sound bit
from "Game of Thrones."
[LAUGHTER]
GABI FERRARA: Yeah, I confess.
That was on purpose.
Because it's true,
winter is coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[RECORD SCRATCH]
JON FOUST: That's going to do
it for Gabi and I this episode.
So thank you all for listening,
and definitely look forward
to seeing you all next year.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah,
talk to you next year.
ROBO MANDEL: From all
of us at the podcast,
we'd like to wish you a Merry
Christmas, a Happy Hanukkah,
a wonderful Fiesta of
Our Lady of Guadalupe,
an excellent Kwanzaa,
a spiritual Omisoka,
and a magical Saturnalia.
And if you're just
into science, we
hope that all your
hypotheses come true.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
s